It's 8:15pm in Afghanistan right now.
And at this time, 10 days ago,
I was sitting
in an eight-foot-by-eight-foot cell
in the basement
of a maximum-security prison in Kabul,
where I was being held captive
by the Taliban.
I'd been in that cell for 104 days,
and yet, I was one of the lucky ones.
But I'm getting ahead of myself.
Let me go back to the beginning.
This is me.
I'm five years old and living
in an Afghan refugee camp
in Peshawar, Pakistan.
You can see the two patches
on my UNHCR-donated jeans.
One patch is an American flag
and the other is the Statue of Liberty,
the quintessential beacons
of the American dream I so badly wanted.
But as a refugee,
I didn't have a state to call home.
And not having a state,
I didn't have rights.
And not having rights,
I didn't have a voice.
I needed someone to advocate for me.
And I was fortunate to have two advocates.
My parents, who had emigrated
to the US four years ahead of me,
fought tirelessly to get me to America
for those four years.
They gave me a voice.
They gave me the American dream.
And my parents' advocacy
allowed me to join them,
to emigrate to Omaha, Nebraska,
to go to high school in the states
to serve in the military,
to graduate as a Tillman Scholar
from Georgetown University,
to get accepted into medical school.
I became the American dream.
(Cheers and applause)
And in my dream,
everything came full circle.
This past summer,
I deferred one dream for another
when I put medical school on hold,
founded Human First Coalition,
an organization dedicated
to aiding Afghans in need.
Having spent the first
17 years of my life stateless,
I rather abruptly found myself
in the role of the humanitarian aid worker
who had shaped so much of my life.
I became that advocate
and that voice for others.
And becoming an aid worker,
I got to provide food,
medical care and shelter
for thousands of Afghans.
I got to operate resettlement flights
for thousands more,
and I got to make multiple trips to Kabul,
with the Taliban’s blessing,
to oversee it all.
But then, on December 18, 2021,
everything changed.
That morning, which started off
like any other morning,
I was suddenly, inexplicably
and unexpectedly
taken into Taliban custody.
As I was being driven
to the Taliban’s General Directorate
of Intelligence headquarters,
I was told that I just needed
to answer a few routine questions,
and then I’d be sent back to my hotel.
Instead, a few hours later,
I was brought into that basement room.
Three roommates, no blanket,
no mattress, no pillow, no sun,
no way to communicate
with the outside world
and no clue what was to become of me.
And from that moment on,
I stayed in that basement
in the dead of the Afghan
winter, for 105 days.
The entire time, I feared that I might be
taken in front of a firing squad,
at any minute.
And on the 45th day,
I was beaten and tortured
by 11 men wielding pipes,
after eight days on a hunger strike.
I had done nothing wrong.
But again, I was lucky.
I not only had several
exceptional advocates,
but I had a state.
The US government game me a voice
and asserted my human rights,
and that's what ultimately
led to my release
10 days ago.
(Applause)
And on the day of my release,
following a four-hour flight
from Kabul to Qatar,
the euphoria I felt as I walked off
that plane is indescribable.
But amidst the triumph
and joy of homecoming,
something was amiss.
On the day of my release,
I returned to society
to find that the humanitarian crisis
in Afghanistan was only getting worse,
the whole world was fixated on Ukraine,
and nearly every Afghan
resettlement effort
was on pause or had ground
to a screeching halt,
with no effective resolution in sight.
And that was a huge letdown.
And that is why I decided
that before even visiting my family,
I had to get back to work.
Because the truth of the matter
is 95 percent of Afghans
are currently not getting enough to eat.
22.8 million are facing
crisis levels of hunger.
97 percent are living
below the poverty line.
And 9 million are living
in extreme poverty.
And these are the individuals
who fought alongside us
in the international coalition
for the last 20 years.
They are our allies.
They are our brothers and sisters,
and they are in desperate straits.
The magnitude of the work ahead
is staggering.
But we have to start somewhere.
And the question becomes
"What should we do?"
In my mind, four things.
First, we must bolster
humanitarian aid provisions
for the international community
by increasing support for and donations
to grassroots organizations
that have infrastructure to ensure
aid is getting directly into the hands
of the people who need it the most.
And that's not just my organization --
there are so many support-worthy groups
doing exceptional work in Afghanistan,
and we need resources now.
Second, we, government
and citizens of the 36 countries
who fought in Afghanistan
must keep our promises
to our Afghan allies,
to whom we owe a debt,
by fast-tracking their resettlement,
be it in the United States or elsewhere.
(Applause)
This, first and foremost,
necessitates resettling refugees
who are currently waiting
in camps around the world,
to reach a place that they can call home.
It also calls upon the international
community to increase quotas
for Afghan allies
to accept more at-risk Afghans
for permanent resettlement
and to expand programs
like humanitarian parole,
to generate more pathways
for those in need.
Third ...
As we find pathways forward
for these individuals,
we must not separate families,
we must preserve them.
(Applause)
Or, at the very least,
create strict limits
for the amount of time that families
can be separated.
Family separation like mine
generates irreparable harm.
But clear and specific change
to existing admission policies
can ensure that other minors
do not face the same fate
that befell me and my family.
Fourth -- and this is the most
important of them all --
we must reestablish an international
diplomatic presence in Afghanistan,
to hold the Taliban accountable
for their actions
and provide consular services
to the people.
It opens a channel
to address Taliban’s actions,
rather than cutting off,
isolating and eliminating
avenues for influence.
And I've witnessed what engagement
with the Taliban can look like firsthand.
The negotiations that resulted
in my release from captivity
were the direct result of effective
diplomacy with the Taliban
on the world stage.
Diplomats spoke to each other openly
and resolved an issue of mutual concern.
And while the success of this discussion
is perhaps an anomaly,
the kind of diplomacy
demonstrated by my release
can and should serve as a model
for achieving other desired change
for the future of Afghanistan,
such as the restoration
of girls' education above grade six,
freedom of press,
bolstering women's rights,
and most urgently,
increasing humanitarian assistance.
At the same time --
(Applause)
At the same time, our diplomacy
can't be a blank check.
The Taliban must live up
to their end of the bargain
to demonstrate that they are ready
to engage in diplomacy,
as an actor that upholds
basic human rights,
that ensures necessary freedoms
and that does not take or hold hostages.
(Applause)
At the end of the day,
the situation in Afghanistan
is an extremely complex one.
It can't be summed up
in an eight-minute talk
I wrote four days ago,
emerging from captivity.
Yet there are tangible solutions,
and I'm in the privileged position
of being able to advocate for them,
but I'm here today to tell you
that you are too.
The truth of the matter is,
especially in the case of Afghanistan,
change has always and will continue
to start with everyday people.
This fall, tens of thousands of people
from around the world
banded together at the grassroots level
to aid Afghans in need.
You don't need to be an expert to engage,
to volunteer, to contribute, to lobby,
or even to simply welcome a refugee
to advocate for them.
As Margaret Mead once said,
"Never doubt that a small group
of thoughtful, committed citizens
can change the world.
Indeed, it's the only thing
that ever has."
On the afternoon
of my release 10 days ago,
I, at long last, climbed out
of my basement cell
and into the sunlight,
without anything binding my hands
or covering my eyes.
I could see the sky.
I traveled out of the prison
through Kabul city in a Corolla sedan.
I passed the American embassy
and arrived at the Kabul
International Airport.
I walked onto the tarmac,
I climbed into the C-17,
I shook hands with American,
Qatari and British diplomats,
and suddenly, I was a free man again.
But again, I was one of the lucky ones.
Ultimately, being a captive reminded me
of a time when I was helpless
and needed a voice.
Now that I'm released,
I have my voice back,
and, mercifully, it puts me in a position
where I can advocate
for that little boy
with the Statue of Liberty patch
on his UNHCR-donated jeans,
chasing the American dream.
I hope you'll join me.
(Applause)